how can the world's population be
collapsing if we're still growing that's
the conundrum it really is
counter-intuitive last year there were
only 700 000 babies being born so
there's a 22 drop already in the UK
countries like Italy are 55 down
Germany's 36 percent down Japan's 55
down I don't know why we're being told
there's absolute nonsense about
population explosions when that was a
thing of the past what clearly occurred
was a deferring of Parenthood it wasn't
that people suddenly decided okay well
I'm not gonna have children it was more
that people decided Well I'm not going
to do it now is 25 27 I'm gonna wait
till I'm 30. and that's the pattern
actually more childless men than
childless woman
and I think men need to understand that
this applies to them just as much
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People our brilliant guest
today is a data scientist demographer
and the creator of a very very good and
important uh film called birth Gap
Stephen J Shaw welcome to trigonometry
thank you for inviting me here oh it's a
great pleasure to have you on the show
uh you are talking about an issue that I
genuinely think will be the biggest
conversation uh over the next five to
ten years that all of Western societies
and actually frankly societies outside
the West are going to be having and
seeing as crucial to their survival
frankly before we get into all of that
though who are you what has been your
journey through life how do you find
yourself sitting here talking to us well
I didn't expect I'd find myself talking
to anybody about a filmmaking I never
intended to be a filmmaker my background
is first of all in engineering computer
coding for 20 years I've run a data
analytics company out of the US doing
forecasting and data predictions for
Industries like the car industry and
seven years ago I saw some data that
basically pointed to the world's
population collapsing that shocked me so
much that I decided I needed to write a
book about it my younger son said Dad
younger people don't read books anymore
we watch documentaries I thought well
there's no way I'm ever going to do that
that's the end of this story for me
until I came across someone who was in
in that world and seven years later yeah
the birth Gap cellist World documentary
yeah it is out you should have made a
tick tock documentary if you really want
to reach the young people just 20
seconds but birth Gap I've had a chance
to watch part of it and as I say it's
super important
um explain to everybody look we all know
right the population of the world is
exploding you know we're going to be on
9 billion people by whenever we're never
going to have enough resources we're all
gonna die the planet's gonna burn we've
got 12 good harvests left and all of
that isn't that all true and right so
how can the world's population be
collapsing if we're still growing that's
the conundrum it really is
counter-intuitive
but it's true the reason the world's
population is still growing is only
because people are living longer and
surviving longer in fact in the case of
countries like India for example like
parts of Africa where many people would
have died in childhood that didn't
happen 30 40 years ago so the plant
we've got a lot of young people who will
simply live through their lives and
that's a good thing but that's not going
to go on forever we know we will max out
at no more than 11 billion possibly a
little bit less but we're aging so all
growth is coming from aging and if you
look at the total number of babies being
born on the planet we hit a maximum
around 2014 of 143 million babies being
born that year it's never been higher
and I don't think it'll be as high again
more recently that's down to 132 million
so we're basically 10 million down
already in 10 years compared to what we
were in 2014 that's globally that
includes sub-Saharan Africa
um if you look at countries like where I
live Japan it's just frightening and so
is China and so is much of Europe
um frankly the rest of the world is on
the same path what I'm getting at though
Stephen is to people who are not
familiar with the issue that we're
talking about which is the fact that
we're not having enough kids basically
to put it simply The Narrative has been
for many many years for decades actually
that there's a population bomb there's a
book of the that name that had a huge
impact on how people thought about this
yes that the the expanding population of
human beings on the planet was a
fundamental threat to the people who
were already alive but also to the
planet itself and what you're saying is
the opposite of that which is really not
having enough children so how does one
reconcile that if it's the first time
they've encountered your your data and
your information well the data the
information we're being given is wrong
uh vastly outdated we already knew back
in the 70s that the world's population
was going to Peak we already knew it was
going to Peak at around what we are now
and we because we saw falling birth
rates everywhere at that time almost
everywhere but the trend was constant
but these voices have been there and
they've infuriated me and I think that's
one of the reasons I made the
documentary because I thought I'm
involved in data prediction I've three
children I'm trying to educate there
were teenagers at that time to prepare
for the future why don't I know and not
only that the clients I have including
some pretty senior Executives in
Industries around the world who I'm
talking to about planning and
forecasting no one in those corporations
is talking about what what we're talking
about here population Decline and
collapse so I felt that nobody knows
about this so what are these voices why
is it that we through education systems
through the media are bombarding us with
this utter nonsense about population
explosions yes the world's population
did increase and clearly is still aging
but the underlying Trend which is what
we need to be focused on is downwards so
I I I you know something's become
institutionalized
to
educate us I'm not sure it's
brainwashing but I wonder frankly but
we're being educated with information
using charts where people start telling
us the population in the year 1800 was
down here one billion
and these curves go up like this and
they say this is where we are now and
then they stop and what they might even
do is look upwards implying that we're
going out forever that's what I thought
seven years ago I'm sure it's what my
kids thought because the textbooks they
used they showed me that's what they
showed but we know that we're going to
Plateau because there's so few babies
being born now we've known this for a
very long time so anybody who wants to
talk honestly about population will be
telling you yes we went through this but
we know it's going to maximize going to
Plateau we're then going to become a
much older planet with people frankly
who are going to be
um you know in need of care and will not
probably have the care that they need
because workforces are going to shrink
and then it's going to decline that's
the real story of population and for
Many Nations another problem I have
frankly is when people talk about total
population this is nonsense what matters
to you and me are our own countries
predominantly or the countries we like
to visit or our own communities in fact
taking the total population of the
planet well fine but we also need to be
looking at what's happening under our
own noses and for the UK if I can just
share with you something
in the UK right now there are around 900
000 people aged exactly 50. I like that
number because 50 year olds will retire
in about 20 years so 900 000.
last year there were only 700 000 babies
being born so there's a 22 drop already
in the UK in terms of that ratio now in
20 years time whenever 50 year olds go
to retire
newborns will be the ones who are
finishing school just about to take the
jobs in the workforce
countries like Italy are 55 down
Germany's 36 percent down Japan's 55
down so you know when I look at that you
realize that life is going to change for
so many countries and only for young and
older like I don't know why we're being
told this absolute nonsense about
population explosions when that was a
thing of the past you've searched very
briefly on why this is not a good thing
so but apart from that why isn't it a
good thing
whether it's a good thing or bad thing
we need to prepare for it no let's say
someone says it's good someone says it's
bad the world is going to change
and I think
anyone surely would want to know how the
world's going to change
I assume that I was educating my kids
for a future that was going to be
similar to my generation
you know so putting them on the same
path the same education same career path
I would have expected a similar
hopefully retirement path
but when you realize that the structure
of societies where typically there's
been a much smaller number of older
people and a much larger size of
Workforce that that is Shifting to
become what I call an inverted world
where there's so many old people to take
care of and a shrinking Workforce what
does that mean well it means many things
um first of all
taxes are going to increase
significantly if we're going to be able
to keep the same level of health care
for older people something like I
believe two-thirds of all health care
costs
um
are devoted to older people so those are
going to expand I don't know how the NHS
is going to cope with that in the UK
different mind health services elsewhere
but you've also got Social Security
you've also got pension systems most
people think I did too
that the money we
take as pensioners I'm not quite there
yet but the money we will get is the
money that we were paying while we're
working but it's not the money we pay
and towards pension systems in most
countries today goes to pay for current
retirees
so any generation is expecting or
needing to appoint younger generations
to keep paying in to support those
pensions so this is just an idea of the
changes that we're going to be looking
at there are many others as well so
Francis I'm not saying that the world's
population is
to small too big I'm saying A change is
about to happen and this change will
last for the rest of the century it's
going to be a very long slow and I think
quite painful change
so I just wanted people to understand
that the world is not going to be the
same for you know much the rest of the
century and so what are the reasons
behind this why is this happening
Stephen
trellisness
um
whenever I started
my research
um
I
couldn't understand why no one had
really been able to explain why birth
rates have been falling in Many Nations
at almost exact same rate starting at
almost the exact same time so if you
take Japan
around
1973-74 there was a very sharp fall and
birth rates Italy it happened at the
same time Germany just a little bit
earlier
many people have theories that oh in
Japan it's work-life balance they work
too hard enough
I would say is probably true but you
couldn't say that of Italy necessary
[Laughter]
um
in Italy it was blamed on something else
it was blamed and youth unemployment
Spain too Germany had other reasons
couldn't believe that this was a big
coincidence in fact if you look at this
trend
started in these places
at the same time and that spread
throughout those regions it didn't ever
go back to normal it kind of was a
progressive thing that just spread
across now the entire
more developed industrialized world and
now I'm far into the developing world
so the idea that there wasn't a common
explanation was to me almost an
impossibility
so I said I set out to see if I could
find a connection and it took a year and
a half before I was even able to come up
with a an hypothesis
and that hypothesis finally formed in a
bar in Tokyo
there's not many scientific hypotheses
conform to the bars and oh maybe there
are I don't know
um after a year and a half I noticed
something strange
um that I couldn't find all that many
people who had no brothers and sisters
of course some but not that many
and to have birth rates below on average
to children per woman you have to have a
lot of people either with no children or
with only one child or a mix thereof
and in this particular bar this night I
was there with some friends and there's
other people coming and I said to myself
okay tonight I'm going to try and ask at
least 10 people if they're brothers and
sisters and if it's not more than one or
two you know I think there's a thesis
here I ended up asking 15 Japanese
people and I think one
didn't have any brothers and sisters all
the rest were two three four one even
had seven wow okay I felt at that moment
I have to find a way to analyze
childlessness in a way it hadn't been
done before usually the way we measure
childlessness is waiting until people
are 45 years old and that means there's
a long lag and the analysis is is a lot
more difficult to do so that was my
challenge then and that's the one thing
I was able to identify and be clear
I will say this and please keep this in
the edit I will support a hundred
percent anybody who decides they do not
want children I will be the biggest
supporter this is not about trying to
coerce people to have children who do
not want car
repeat
but those people are the minority
compared to if you look in countries
like
um Japan Europe where this trend has
been in place for for many decades less
so in the US and other countries they're
still transitioning but what you end up
with in countries with very high
childlessness so for example right now
in Japan you have challenges running
around 35 percent in Italy's 40 percent
around 80 percent of those people had
planned to have children
so four out of five people have planted
the child
and life took its course and that's why
I ended up calling it unplanned
childlessness so the reason is unplanned
childlessness
and then the question is why
um why do people in the end not have the
families they want to have but that's
that's your show so well we'll get into
that in a second but let's first of all
just if we stick with the chronological
order of it the initial triggers which
you're talking about in Germany it's the
late 60s and other countries it's it's
the mid 70s and you've talked uh in you
talk in birth Gap in the film about
economic triggers so it's the oil shock
of the 70s and so on is that your
contention that this is economically
driven triggered triggered economically
triggered yes I suppose the obvious
question from where I'm sitting then is
I mean I I'm not much of a historian but
I have studied some history like the oil
shock of the 70s was not the worst thing
that's ever happened to humanity you
know and human beings had went on and
had children after the Great Depression
they went on and had children after
World War II and during World War II and
all of the terrible experiences of human
beings have always had yes they've
always we've always bounced back yes
we've never had this issue as far as I'm
aware of before
so why is essentially economic
disruption why did that have such a huge
triggering effect on this particular
issue so it's a great question
um and I don't cover this in a
documentary so let me go a little bit
deeper
um and just explain I've lived in Japan
for six years but I've employed a
researcher worked with academics how to
look into the history of Japan around
this time if you look at the early 70s
in Japan what was happening was many
people were moving into cities getting
new jobs working for the car companies
electronic companies things were looking
good and around that time things started
to get more expensive rents started to
go up
um more and more women were looking to
work but there were a few kindergarten
spaces so there's tensions in
communities trying to balance uh
affordability of Apartments along with
finding enough kindergarten spaces
still birth rates were relatively High
then the old shock hits suddenly and
Japan was the largest oil importer in
the world at the time so their entire
growth required oil at that moment
prices went up even more Commodities you
see in the documentary shelves that were
empty this this was a stress Society
anyway
then something happened on what
clearly occurred was a deferring of
Parenthood it wasn't that people
suddenly decided that okay well I'm not
gonna have children
um it was more that people decided Well
I'm not going to do it now is 25 27 I'm
going to wait till I'm 30. and that's
the pattern
um so when we look at America well many
countries actually but to take the
mortgage crisis of 0.708 you can look at
America you could look at Canada
Malaysia Netherlands even New Zealand
around that time childlessness was
hovering around 15 percent
um so let me explain a little bit if I
can on this as quickly as what do you
see with childlessness are waves waves
that happen when going back to the UK in
the 1960s the most common Aid of
children was age 20 to 24.
30 years later in the 90s that had
shifted to 25 to 29. so it became
natural to have children a little bit
later you wind up clock forward to now
and that's 30 to 34 in the UK is the
most common age for women to have a
child you then interject some form of
economic shock into that and you're
causing further delays into women's 30s
into the woman's late 30s that means
frankly
women aren't able to have the children
they want to have
so just to come back to your point that
yes during famines and Wars you're
absolutely right those times in the past
have been times when basically society's
delay having children but because it was
normal to have children younger at the
end of the war at the end of the
pandemic at the end of the crisis women
which generally still young enough to be
able to have the families they want to
have today that's changed
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
our war shows still go out at 7pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and look and let's be really honest
about this we're not
women are being sold to lie they're
being sold to lie of you know you can
have it or you can go out and work and
have a career and do all of this and
then have kids later on in your 30s and
the reality is you're going to be far
less fertile in your late 30s than you
will be if you have children in your
early 20s that question is going to make
such a great little Twitter short mate
the reality is women have been sold down
in other words let me darling what's
going wrong
and I have to be a little bit cautious
here because come on it's called
trigonometry just let it rip yeah
so in my words if I can yeah
it's like keep the distance away from
your inflammatory language yeah sorry I
I
um you're not 100 wrong you're not
you're not at all but the way I see I
don't think anyone's doing the selling I
I and I hope it's going to be easy to
kind of explain the reality that has not
been shared up until now for whatever
reason I think if you look at younger I
have three children who are now in their
20s I think
young people
have and their parents frankly
are of the belief mostly that if you get
an education or training
it's then a good thing clearly
to get a job to get a career build on
that to a point of stability
and then maybe in your 30s why not what
we're not aware of for whatever reason
is that women's fertility a Falls much
faster than expected that there's a lot
of variability in it some people some
women are very fertile to 40 or older
some lose their fertility by age 30. so
we don't know about that variation like
they're there for the risk also we don't
know that the quality of a woman's eggs
a woman is born with all of the eggs she
will ever have in her life women do not
make new eggs
so two things happen during that time
and it's covered in a documentary of Kim
Kardashian's uh fertility doctor include
to explain how this happens you lose
both the count of eggs but you also lose
the quality of eggs and then a third
thing happens which is the ability to
carry a baby to term the risks
associated with that go up so
um to be honest with you and you'll see
it in part two of the documentary which
is not quite out yet a little bit in
part one where I started asking women in
their 40s and 50s without children had
the intended to have children and it was
a very delicate subject and I have to be
I have to say people watching this in
the situation
these are people internally grieving the
fact that they had never families and
you see deeply emotional scenes
and it's heartbreaking is absolutely
heartbreaking it's
you know something that I think we
should know more about
um as a society you know just the fact
that we've got to be sensitive to people
so just to give you an example
um some people perhaps many
um
who don't have children in the workplace
will see a colleague bringing their
child to work or talking about their
children many of these people go to
Pieces when this happens they'll go to
the restroom they'll go to the toilet
and just stay there they'll go and you
know have a walk we don't realize they
certainly I didn't the internal anguish
that happens so to your point
um Society I agree is not informing
people men or women because men are
trying to partner with women if they
want kids who are able to have children
men also are in the dark here and
um so the question why that's happening
I don't know it's remarkable we teach
people so much about biology in schools
but we don't cover this
so it's it's got a chance well you're
right I think that a lot and this is I
said it on Twitter a while back and
people got annoyed with me as they do
whenever anyone brings this up but we
we've got to a position where a lot of
people but particularly in this case
women are are going to end up in a
position when they're not happy they're
not happy with where they've ended up
and I'm curious I mean the economics of
this I imagine are significant because
you know my wife for example right now
she she's she's not back to full-time
work by any stretch of imagination and
our son is a year old and I don't think
she'll be back to full-time work for a
long time and she doesn't want to be
back to full-time work for a long time
but for a lot of people that is not a
position in that they can they can
afford they can't afford to to
especially if you know both parents have
a high paying job and they need that
money to maintain the lifestyle that
they wish to have and that they used to
uh that's that's an economic difficulty
that I think didn't exist in the past
when 40 50 years ago a family of four
could live on one person's income
typically the dad would go out to work
the mum wouldn't and they could live on
that comfortably and he wasn't as big a
deal now economically that's not uh
viable but also societally that's not
quite viable either like the choice of
giving up a lot of money to stay home
with the kids doesn't seem like a very
appealing option to a lot of people as
well
partly I I have to say again that people
don't want to have children like we have
to just accept that I think the
challenge is the conflict then for those
who do want to and are trying to find
the right time I I think the best way
for me to answer this is to say
if we're going to find a solution to
this problem we've got to make it more
flexible for people to have what I'm
calling educational Pathways and career
Pathways that make it easier to do
things at the same time or to take
breaks for from one or the other why are
we cramming all of our education into
the first three four years I I still
take classes college level classes uh
because I like to keep up to date with
things and it's it's refreshing to study
something that you want to learn at the
time you want to learn it that's
relevant to you
um I think we need to make education
more flexible so people are able to have
children younger
um why not have people start their
careers for the first time age 30 or 35
we're living longer now the idea of
retirement
I don't know what the french are
thinking about right now but retirement
the age 63 is there 65 yeah it's it's
going to be 75 at the young people today
watching this you're not going to retire
until you're at least 75 to 80 years 100
yeah so why not start careers it's 30 35
if you're going to have a 40 50 year
career anyway so I don't have all of the
answers here but I know the current
structures that we have are
for sure not helping or Henry many many
people and also the thing that we don't
talk about as well is that women like to
partner with people who are if not a
similar level to them education wise and
earning wise they prefer it if they're
higher but then what happens if if you
get women who go to university and by
the way there are people I'm in favor of
women going to University and you know
educate I'm not really educating
themselves even they're just jokes
just jokes mate um so if you know so
women go into you know education they
have they come out they have this
amazing career they have this amazing
job and then they want a partner
and then they realize that the partner
that they want comes from a very very
small pool in which a lot of women are
competing for that small pool of men
well that's right
um so this is called hypergamy it's it's
it's absolutely true that women do
cross-culturally
prefer to partner with men who are at
least as successful whatever that means
as they are and that's not going to
change because that's part of who we are
as a species
man don't mind man will marry down but
actually prefer less uh women are more
educated it seems to be we've got to
accept that that's a reality no
your point is absolutely right because
if you look at colleges in the US right
now almost two-thirds of people at U.S
colleges are are women even in Thailand
it's 60 it's it's a global Trend that
women are focusing more in education
this is a problem I don't have an answer
to this uh in some ways I have to say
that you know men need to be studying
harder you know or not dropping out of
colleges I mean I heard recently the
dropout rate for men at U.S colleges is
much much higher than one
so this is another problem we have to
confront maybe if you personalize it you
would say if if a woman wants to be sure
of finding someone you know don't leave
it until you're 35 and through all your
your graduate education Etc because
you're right at that point in time there
will be a very small pool of people who
you might feel you want to partner
because that's the that's the challenge
and you know
sorry for
these women are particularly you know I
have relatives of mine who are doctors
you you work really hard at school you
then go to university and then you then
have to go through medical school you
have to qualify and by the time you've
done all of your exams you're in your
early 30s mid-30s and you're pretty much
just started your career and then you
have to go oh right now I have to think
about kids
it's it's huge huge it's huge and you
wonder how what are we gonna do to be
able to actually overcome this Challenge
and do we just need to start talking
more honestly about female biology
one of the interviews that we did uh was
a young German medical student
um it didn't make the final cut of the
documentary but I will be including her
in some future coverage I think she was
23 24. and
um she had decided to take a year out of
medical school to have a child and
[Applause]
um she was laughing with us yes it's a
struggle but you know you should see
what it's like to be a doctor and have a
child and she had decided that if she
didn't make that the right time for her
she'd probably end up being childless
because she saw so many
older doctors who were childless
and she was making she made a work um to
be honest with you she was one of the
happiest positive energy people and of
course when you're 22 23 24 you do have
more energy for things like that and
again I have to say I don't want to
pressure people to have children younger
than they want but we have to make
societies more flexible so that those
who might consider this are better able
to do so well look none of us wants to
force this is kind of I think part of
the reason that we can't have this
conversation the way we need to is you
and us to some extent are very tense
about coming across as telling other
people what to do none of us just to be
clear none of the three of us wants to
tell women or any other human beings how
they should live their lives however we
are also starting to see that some of
the ways we've been living as a society
are not generally speaking creating the
highest amount of fulfillment meaning
purpose and happiness for people right
and so we should be able to knowledge
both of those at the same time I think
that's really really important actually
and you know we make all the jokes about
it to diffuse the tension but I know
exactly why you are very careful about
this because it's a very difficult issue
to talk about and we'll come back to
talk about the issue itself in a second
but one of the ways that this difficulty
of this issue showed up recently is your
experiences at Cambridge University tell
us about that or my lack of experience
your lack of experience yeah
um so I was invited by a student at
Cambridge University to give a
presentation to show the documentary in
a q a and I was greatly honored and
these students who want to invite me to
universities anywhere I'll try and be
there
um the student's name was Charlie
Bentley Pastor who I didn't know at that
time but I've got to know her quite well
since and um she explained that at
Cambridge University these days it
seemed to be quite a thing to protest
and that she wore me we might have some
people who were upset by the documentary
well when I first heard that
um to be clear I'll screen the
documentary 40 50 times
including to universities International
students from various podcasts I think
there's now over fifteen thousand
comments have been written about the
documentary
um
not one of those comments or one of
those prior events would have ever given
me any reason to think that anyone would
want to cancel my documentary why it's
about life it's about people it's
people's voices I don't even come up
with a conclusion in it I simply say
here is the world and here is the other
hard data real people and most of the
people I interview are women
in fact the entire crew other than me
there's about nine of us involved in
making a documentary they were all women
except me and it wasn't I went out to
try and find women to make this
documentary woman gravitated towards
this project because
they want to also hear answers from
other people
so
uh when Charlie told me there might be a
few protesters that was well okay
um my first thought was I'd like to meet
them I'd like to sit down with them I'd
like to talk to them about why they're
protesting and talk to them about their
lives and how the world's going to
change
what actually happened was on another
scale uh there were protesters in the
street a week before the event took
place Varsity magazine wrote a hit piece
on me uh challenging the documentary but
giving no reason for it whatsoever yet
no one ever contacted me no protester
said hi Stephen can you explain this
data they didn't even watch the full
documentary they only watched the intro
to it huh
and what is the thrust of that criticism
well the reason it was actually canceled
was in Jordan's College felt that
there'd be too much noise protest during
exam time so that was the excuse well
that's the heckless veto but why are
they heckling in the first place what's
wrong with with talking about this issue
they've called me anti-feminist
misogynist bigoted racist
racist yes and most recently fascist
welcome to the club
that's what we all are now why why you
okay look anti-feminism misogynist I'm
not saying you are obviously you're not
but I can see how people can add two
plus two and get about 75 right what
does it have to do with racism it's
ridiculous I mean clearly people are
just trying to use terms as Charlie puth
they're trying to intimidate other
students and academics from attending
this event so by throwing out these
words actors are not it's just a warning
to stay away so the question there goes
these people don't know me they don't
know the documentary there's something
the subject matter they don't like and I
hear it might be to do with the
definition of a woman I think putting
the term mother and woman in the same
sentence today is provocative to some
people perhaps that's what's been
explained to me
so I I you know either one I'm at the
other scientist you know for me it
wasn't just a cancellation of the
documentary it was a attempt to cancel
un data I mean the data I gather is
purely from government sources and it's
an attempt to cancel the voices of the
world mostly from women and Uh
something's clearly very very wrong in
society when universities were places
where people go to absorb new ideas and
to reject them or accept them or change
them that even now in universities least
of all Cambridge so I'm actually going
back next week
um we're going to try one more time
before the end of this semester to
screen it I think I've been told if it's
canceled again I'll become the most
canceled person ever at Cambridge
University because everyone else who got
canceled eventually went back and were
able to kind of do their uh uh Speech or
whatever so we'll see what happens so I
didn't know this part of it I thought
the reason that they were upset out with
your documentary is you know you were
telling women to get back in the kitchen
that that was their interpretation but
it's not it's the mere idea that the
mothers are women essentially to be
honest with you no one's given me a
specific reason I mean even if you read
firstly there's no specific reason why
this documentary is in any way upsetting
to anybody so the interpretation I've
just given you
um is what I've been told that the group
of people the 90 people who were due to
come and protest often protest against
trans-related issues and that's very sad
I mean these are people actually want to
reach out to to sit down with to talk
about their lives I I I I hope I get
that chance that's because you haven't
met them I'm just kidding but Stephen
moving on there was this part of this
which I I feel we're not talking about
which is fertility levels are also
dropping as well so I was reading about
certain studies that were looking at
male fertility and saying the quality of
sperm in I think it's something like men
in their 20s is inferior to quality of
sperm of men in their 50s and how much
of an effect is that having on this
particular
um
this comes up quite a lot and the answer
is if it is having an effect we haven't
really seen it yet it may be starting to
be part of the data we'll we'll see in
future
but one thing I'm very sure of that is
not the reason for the start of this
trend this trend started in the late 60s
and 70s and has basically been on the
Continuum since then so applying modern
or more recent possible explanations
doesn't work out I I get perhaps the
most amusing one
um I gotta comment on one of the the
sites that uh they thought Ronald Reagan
was the reason for that this whole
problem when it started in Japan in the
1970s so people are often taking things
that they hear that are more recent than
applying I get this a lot but now you
have to find a reason that can explain
this going all the way back to the 70s
and to explain why it started in some
countries before others only then can
you understand this well I feel like we
still haven't quite got there in terms
of our conversation here because we
talked about the economic shocks that
people experienced in those countries
yeah and the dose Society societies that
have seen a a reduction in the ratio
between earnings and the cost of living
essentially right it's become harder for
a family to to survive economically
um but I still feel like there's got to
be some kind of cultural stroke
psychological Dimension to this where we
have become more risk-averse and I think
we see that in other areas of life as as
cultures generally and I I certainly
would posit at least that the way we
talk about climate change and the way we
talk about the future of the planet has
an impact on how people feel do you know
the number of times I've talked to young
people and probably at one point thought
myself prior to really educating myself
about these issues properly you know
there is this sort of human beings of
the virus narrative that's going around
you know what I mean like there's too
many of us we're causing too much of a
strain on the planet why would we bring
another person into this world that's
about to collapse anyway like that is
definitely out there as well do you
think that's a contribution teaching
Factor here I worry that that will be a
a contributing factor in the decade or
two ahead because I do hear that more
and more from younger people today
frankly birth rates are already so low
if that you know that could put us
really over the age if that becomes the
case and it's sad because you know I I
first of all I don't think we should be
ranking our crises I'm as concerned
about the planet as the next person uh
the dialogue that we have around the
environment you know frustrates me
frankly because we only seem to talk
about certain aspects of it rather than
for example Technical Solutions that
that we should be talking about we
should be talking about everything if
we're genuinely worried about it so
um but the idea that
whatever you think in terms of the
environment that someone can take say to
somebody else do not have children
that's morally wrong you might want to
say be careful how you raise your
children you know in terms of
consumption maybe that's okay but I've
heard of situations I've heard of
professors in universities in the US
telling the classes they should not have
children
and that's just shocking that's that's
beyond immoral to me if you were to say
let me bring in one of the other points
about my findings and all of these
countries once
a person once a woman becomes a mother
family structure has not changed in
decades so back to the US in the 80s
back to Japan in in the 70s the
proportion of women in Japan having four
or more children was six percent in the
1970s today it's exactly the same
now that was quite a shock to me to find
out actually once a woman has her first
child she is typically going on to have
as many children as it looks like she
would want to have because that that's
that structure just does not change but
as a new father just turned to Jake
briefly that makes total sense to me
because once you have your first it's
like they're like Pringles once you pop
you can't stop like you're gonna have as
many as you're gonna have because
they're great you know what I mean for
the vast majority of people it's just
the experience transforms you but it's
getting people over that line is what
you're talking about so the reason we
are where we are is not that families
have become smaller it's just there's
way more people not having children at
all yes right
um so but I still feel like we haven't
quite got to why that my sense is my
cultural and climate related explanation
you feel is much more forward-facing but
in terms of why we have dealt with these
economic shocks and the cost of living
issue at in the way that we have do we
have any sort of sense of why for the
first time in in probably human history
we are we're whittling down our own
Society do we have an idea what that is
well to go back to the these triggers
the oil shock the mortgage shock Etc
also in Korea the the um the currency
crisis of the mid 90s there's multiple
examples of this what what you find is a
very quick transition to high
childlessness but it never goes back so
it locks in so the question it to talk
about the culture around this
societal Norms change in some way
that lock in a new pattern and that
pattern is one where people have
children later so I I think what's
happened is frankly
um our societies and this is
cross-cultural I mean you look at Japan
as a culture you look at Europe
different parts of Europe the US even
Brazil is suffering from the exact same
problem even Russia
um and Ukraine so you look at all of
these places and you find that across
all these cultures once people start
delaying Parenthood it gets locked in
and I I equate this a little bit in in
Japan we have words for this
um the the person who was hired a little
a year or two before you is called
senpai
so everyone has a senpai and Senpai has
a senpai and then the people below you
are like kohai so it helps me with this
terminology if you're a particularly a
woman and you've just turned 30 and
you're Senpai and Senpai Senpai have not
had a child yet European as well it's
probably not my time yet because I might
be perceived as you know so you're not
even thinking of it and what you might
be thinking is well when Senpai Senpai
boss's boss has a child then there'll be
a promotional opportunity so I'm gonna
wait for that so I think the way you
know the world kind of welcomes people
um to kind of delay parenting around
this so it becomes a cultural uh
phenomenon but yeah yeah that's
cross-cultural if that makes sense that
makes perfect sense so essentially we're
once you've had the transition from
having children young to not having
children young it becomes a locked in
cultural phenomenon that people
essentially mimetically take on from
others around them and then you add to
that the economic rationale for well
I'll get my career sorted first then
we'll have kids and because of that as
you say 80 of the women who end up being
childless did not intend to be childless
in countries have gone through the full
transition yeah so in the US there's a
lot of women right now hoping to become
a mother her age you know 35 to early
40s and just statistically you just look
at the the chances are are not high I
mean that's one other fact just I I love
sharing if I claim that in every country
except one and the one is Israel I'll
talk about in a moment and every country
I've looked at
women turning 30 without a child only
have a 50 50 chance of ever becoming a
mother
30. in Israel that's 31 it's just a
little bit older
and when I asked people on a survey what
age do you think it's 50 50 40 was the
most common answer so again we have this
mismatch about what is possible we
talked about fertility but fertility is
not the biggest reason people aren't
becoming parents it's because they're
not with a partner at that right time
so they're working on their career 32-33
maybe they do have a partner at that
time now everything's good for one of
them but maybe the other partner isn't
quite ready
or maybe there's a breakup or a divorce
or maybe you actually don't have a
boyfriend girlfriend partner at that
time not having a partner at the right
time is the biggest reason and that's
why I wanted to tell people you know at
Cambridge was that you know like one of
the comments and I think Varsity
Magazine from one student a medical
student was that they don't need to be
told whether they want their children or
not what I want to tell them is actually
it takes to have a child and finding a
partner at the right time is there for
really important and most people skip
over that
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
and it's also the fact as well you know
we're talking about the 60s in
population collapse I mean the pill must
play a massive part in this surely
no
correct
so you would say so and uh the counter
argument to this is that in Japan the
pill was not made legal until 1990.
really really and do you know even today
in Japan
only three percent of women take the
pill
three
it's incredible I didn't know that quite
recently
um but let's go back so the pill I guess
lit 60 70s became commonplace across
much of the industrialized world and we
like you many people me too I'm sure in
the past would have said oh the pill has
enabled women to well in Japan there was
no pill what happened is there was a
huge increase in abortions there
so with or without the pill women were
able to decide whether they wanted
children or not so you have to put that
and by the way I have to say again a
caveat I do not want to have any say on
whether a woman wants to have an
abortion or not that's her choice not
not my business
so the fact that it's a pillow alone you
know that's why I said no to but but for
sure
um women have a lot more control over
their biology
but unfortunately we are not educating
women well or men on high short
fertility Cycles can be and it's also as
well that now women are being fed this
you know the uh this story The and look
it works for some women as well where
they go well you know technology is
getting better and better you can freeze
your eggs I've heard certain companies
say to female Executives or we will
freeze your eggs and we will pay for it
which you think sounds great and you're
going hang on that's really dystopian
it's not just Executives it's young
recruits young women being brought from
University are being sold this as a
benefit and when I first heard of egg
freezing
um I thought this was a great idea I
thought this is part of the solution
um but the more I thought about it when
I realized people are just delaying
Parenthood until they don't have a
partner or they don't have energy
um in a way I love the way he pointed at
me I haven't slept for a year I haven't
looked as good for a year don't point at
me when you say they haven't got energy
so I've got 40 year old dad energy
that's what I've got I'm sure you do
um
hahaha I you know um now I've lost my
tracks I'm so sorry you were talking
about uh egg freezing yeah people
delaying Parenthood to a point where
they're all like me well I think it's
dangerous to assume that egg freezing
will will on mass solve this problem it
may solve it in a very few cases and
that's wonderful
um I've got a fertility doctor in Tokyo
who's just you know were working with me
right now to say how can we let people
know that that's really might be a Last
Hope Resort that may or may not work
so I think we have to put everything in
perspective and um you know if
Technologies get better and people are
able to have children later in life well
that's great but we're just certainly
not there yet Stephen so your key
takeaway message and correct me if any
of this is incorrect is you don't have
as much time as you think yes that's
that's one of your key messages yes and
if you get to 30
and you haven't got kids your chances
statistically speaking of having kids
are 50 50 at that point my wife and I we
had our first son at 39 very late
probably have another one just I my wife
comes from a family like her Granddad
was born as like the 15th child and his
mom was like 58 at the time so she's
maybe got genetically uh in a better
position but you don't have as much time
as you think you don't right you don't
have as much time as you think so if you
want to have children basically you need
to find a partner and try and make it
work by around that time if you haven't
already if you want to be a mother or if
you want to be a parent it's about
prioritization is what's important to
you and if someone decides you know what
I'll take the risk I'm gonna you know
that's fine so I don't want to force
people and none of us are saying but
that's not what I was saying yeah right
I was saying if you want to be a parent
that's kind of the strategy you want to
follow
now societally
uh the question for me is you we touched
on some of the impact earlier but I
actually think we didn't quite go as
deep as we could because when you talk
in in the movie one of the stats you
gave which I was like
whoa you said there are more adult
diapers being sold in Japan than baby
diapers yes already yes
it's been like that for quite a while
actually that is terrifying isn't it yes
um
so you know I live in Japan and the
reason I'm there is because I'm
passionate about this issue I'm actually
passionate about trying to help save
Japan uh one of the great things there
is that everyone in Japan intensely
knows about this topic
um it's on the media every day the
government they're you know making uh
regular you know policy changes to try
and address it so it's a place where I
hope if anywhere in the world can solve
it it might be Japan first
um because you're right another
statistic
um in Japan
this data goes back a few years within
the last five to ten years the average
number of people waiting for a care home
was around 400 000 people
when you get to an age in Japan of
needing a character you can't take care
of yourself you're living alone
that is the moment you can put yourself
on the list to wait for careon so you
need a care home but you can't be on the
list until you need it why because there
aren't enough current spaces the average
time I think from then to wait on the
current place is three years
so you've got people who literally are
unable to take care of themselves and
able to address themselves and able to
do anything living for three years
before that place in the care home opens
up Japan is a template for much of
Europe
um cut us out let me say it here I
haven't said this before but um you know
I'm from the UK originally I didn't have
a vote here but
um because I don't live here but I I'm
pro-brexit
and at the time of brexit
um I you know contacted some newspapers
here to say look I think we should do a
an article using some of the maps I've
created to show how Grim the situation
is in Germany Italy Spain much of Europe
because people need to know just how
fast Europe's going down the hill
economically as well as in terms of the
care of the elderly there
and uh I I I use the slogan if you like
I was using the term it's safer to be
out
because of what's going to happen in
Europe with this rapid aging of all
people that that's already well underway
and um so it's not just Japan it's it's
on our you know or or on your Shores
here in the UK
um and it's catching up so much so fast
in so many parts of the world and I
think what people probably haven't been
able to quantify but it's undoubtedly
the case is an aging Society changes uh
everything it changes whether people
start businesses or not it changes
whether there's innovation in in society
because as we all know that once you get
to a certain age you you become less
flexible and less willing to take a risk
I mean that's why young people are much
more risked hungry because that's the
time you're supposed to be trying things
because you've got time to fail you've
got time to make a mistake you've got
time to do that economically militarily
I mean it just seems to me that this is
a huge issue as I said to you at the
beginning that people don't even
understand the implications of let alone
the implications of the implications the
second order third order fourth order
consequences yeah yeah I we haven't gone
to too many of those but just a very
obvious one is that we're going to have
too much housing for the the number of
people in our societies and today in the
UK that's probably hard to understand
because there's seen it seemed to be the
other way around at the moment but that
will change and you know these are
societies therefore that will have
decaying communities where houses will
become desolate
where communities will become desolate I
feel young people will mostly move away
from those communities I think certain
towns will become what they call magnet
towns that people gravitate towards
mostly younger people which become quite
expensive the older people will be left
in the decaying towns without enough
Health Care taxes are going to vote for
everybody and then you take National
debts so most countries Japan certainly
all countries I want to say have got
significant National debts and these
tend to get larger rather than smaller
well if you have a shrinking Workforce
to pay the interest on those I mean
you're going to have a real pressure on
the younger people
to continue to have anything like the
quality of lifestyle that we have we've
had before
so communities are going to look
different
um and yeah
um
I I really worry about loneliness and
all of this you know we haven't used
that word yet but that is a core word
that I think that we need to apply ah
it's not the right word
people who don't find a partner people
who don't have children when they want
to have children
um are likely to face a level of
loneliness and there's many support
groups online already for this you can
see you can read the stories you can
even read the stories I imagine after
this podcast you'll see comments uh
coming up but people in this situation
who you know who who left it too late
dealing with a level of loneliness but
then you take older people so there's a
community in Japan where I visited where
50 years ago it was filled with younger
families and today it's only older
people but it's mainly older women
living there alone because Partners men
tend to die younger so you have this
situation where we went to the local
grocery store and they we hear that
these women come out maybe once a week
to do the shopping and they're spending
forever talking whilst they're paying
for their groceries was that's the only
person they're getting to talk to weekly
and we've got to do something about this
clearly we can't let people remain in
their Apartments without a sense of
community but we're gonna have to think
about so many issues so many problems
that come out of this that we're not
scratching the surface of yet and
Stephen is the sorry France it's just I
wanted to tell us just one other
question on this
other than sub-Saharan Africa where
people are very happily breeding away
and enjoying big families and and all of
that and there's fewer childless women I
think am I saying anything that's
incorrect yeah but I don't think they're
enjoying having bigger families if if
you the reason people have large
families
is typically because of extreme poverty
yes
once you put in running water and
opportunities for Education that changes
completely right so what you can say is
in substantire in Africa where people
are having fewer children uh year by
year it's quite significant but still
there you have extreme poverty in many
areas and that's causing larger families
I think it's a better way okay that's
the more accurate way of putting it
is there an antidote I've spoken to some
people from Israel recently and they're
telling me you know Jerusalem is the
best place there's kids everywhere blah
blah blah blah is Israel does Israel
offer some kind of solution like where
can we look to for some answers to this
so there's two places that are
interesting one's Israel one's hungry
um Israel is a very stratified Society
I've never been there I hope to go this
year but I can see from the dealer very
clearly you have quite high
childlessness and Rising childlessness
it's about 20 there now but you have 15
of mothers
having six or more children right no
Orthodox I imagine people tell me that
yeah
um but there is something interesting in
Israel the most
uh common family size in Israel is three
children
and that's quite rare usually it's too
so is there a learning there perhaps
again I don't ever want to tell someone
to have more children than they
naturally want but I don't think we're
going to get 15 of mothers in other
countries having six or more children
that that's just not realistic Hungary
is the other one where they have a lot
of policies
um for example in Hungary if you're a
young couple you can get a loan to buy a
house and the loan will increase
depending on how many children
you effectively commit to up to four
so you're going to get a bigger loan to
get by a bigger house without even
having had your first child
if you don't have four children well you
have to pay some of the money back so
you only you actually you only get the
benefit of this loan when you actually
have children no the interest and I'm
not saying that maybe that's coercive
but what is interesting about it is the
actual structure of family size and
Hungary has not changed at all like
everywhere else you don't have any more
people than before and once they become
apparent having one two three four
children but you do see a significant
reduction in jealousness
[Music]
um quite significant and it's too early
yet to say that this is causal
um but it's certainly something I I
think we should look at is there a way
to you know through Lawns encourage
people to take away economic
vulnerability which is there for people
to say look okay if you do have the
children you think you're going to have
you know here's this and you have to pay
back some of it if you don't again I I
don't want to comment necessarily on
what's good or bad here in specific
policies but those are two countries
um I could talk about Russia very
briefly if you wanted to of course the
Russia is also sided with uh as having
policies that have somewhat successfully
encourage people to have more children
and Russia's birth rate did very low and
then did go back up but if you look
underneath this up until 95 the most
common family size in Russia was one
child over half of families were having
only one child
and
um I I don't know why that is but from
95 onwards that started to normalize
normal I mean become more similar to
other countries where two was the most
popular and not the number of people
having only one child fell sharply so it
wasn't really an increase in overall
birth rates it was it was a reduction
and people only having one child whereas
right now in Russia birth rates are just
falling through the roof since around
2015 I believe it is births I think are
done it might be 30 percent
so all of these countries that people
look at and go oh Russia did something
good here it's never as easy as that or
it's rarely as simple as that and do you
think as well part of this problem is
and Constantine has actually mentioned
it more important than anything else is
society particularly Western Society is
very anti-natal so whenever I hear you
talk about South Korea you talk about
and correct me if I'm wrong 0.8 is a
replacement rate in South Korea yes I
was reading about South Korea the other
day when I was researching for this uh
for this interview they have child free
zones
in you know I think it's in the South
and we're in an island in South Korea
and they say you know children allowed
in coffee shops restaurants etc etc and
then you go
and then you wonder why people don't
want kids
South Korea I did film there
um um several people from Korea Pier
it's a culture where there are issues
um work-life balance and you know women
do get paid less than men there are
certain cultural issues you would point
to what's uh the term that's used in the
media is birth strike but none of the
women I actually talked to uh in Korea
were saying well I'm on strike
so I think that's a cute media term the
reality is women in Korea are starting
families very late much later than other
countries and they're not achieving uh
the same family size as other
countries would do Spain's very similar
as well by the way in terms of the
number of people starting families
really late so in those countries you
find very high proportions of families
with only one child again
um I hadn't heard of the child free
Island I must research that but it
sounds horrendous and you know the
antenatalism it is out there
um I you know a hundred percent yeah
yeah oh absolutely you meet so many
people I'll be honest with you I used to
be like that before we had our son I
used to find kids annoying I do and I
think the fewer of them are around
actually the more annoying you find them
because they become the anomaly it's
like almost everybody's had experience
of getting on a plane seeing a baby
going for [__] sake I'm not gonna get
any rest I'm not going to get any sleep
whereas I think if everyone was having
kids around you it would be a whole
different experience because it's like
well it's just part like you get on a
plane there's going to be some kids on
there because there's going to be some
men and some women it's like part of the
thing do you know what I mean yeah so I
think there's an awful amount of it
around do you know the thing that Earth
hits me most
um
there's a term used a lot and we haven't
used it here I don't want to ever use it
but
putting the word child and free in the
same right yeah I call it the CF world
and the CF word is used commonly in the
media it's used in some Academia but
Lord free means free from something
harmful and the idea that children are
harmful
so you put the word free after disease
free germ free debt free mortgage free
things are universally negative
not something that you want and you
don't want not a selective thing so the
idea that there's people out there who
would use the c f term you know as a
parent they find that offensive the idea
that I might want to be free from my
children or if a teacher in school was
saying to my children
when they're younger oh that they are
child free what would that do to a child
hearing from a teacher oh maybe my
parents also want to be free of me I
mean it's it's damaging to children so
this is where I see this well not not
exactly subtle quite obvious
antenatalism creepy and everywhere and I
think that term just has to be called
out for what it is well I think on a
more positive level uh I I always try
and talk about how much I enjoy being a
parent just to get the idea out there
that it's actually a lot of fun it's not
something you want to be free from it's
something for if it's right for you like
you want to make that happen so we're
gonna go to uh supporters only questions
in a second uh on locals and we'll
they've got a bunch of great questions
for you but before we do just start
wrapping it up if I'm watching this I'm
23 years old I'm a young woman I want to
be a parent I do want to be a parent at
some point what are you telling me
um start thinking from now about how
that's gonna best happen for you don't
wait until you're 28 32 35
um and be aware
that you will have to make compromises
almost certainly something will have to
give and if you don't make a decision
for yourself to have a child yes
unplanned jealousness will be the
consequence you may have your career and
that might be fine you might have
friends other extended family that's
fine but the thing that is most likely
to give is family if you don't in some
way start to consider it from age 23.
and if I'm a policy maker listening to
this because there are some of those too
what are you telling me show this
documentary in all your schools
or start education about this in schools
because people need to know about
fertility challenges from high school
age they need to know that there's only
50 50 chance of becoming a mother a man
that's only a little bit older too
people need to know that when they're
planning their lives policy makers
spending more money on
you know enabling people to have
children may be a good idea more
kindergartens that might be good but
those things don't fix the problem they
never have and I don't think they ever
will
it's about information stay information
it's been an absolute pleasure having
you on before we move to locals our
final question is always the same what's
the one thing we're not talking about
that we really should be well unplanned
childlessness I know I've already said
it yeah
um and I you know I but I'll say on
plant challenges in a broader context
here we've talked a lot about women
becoming unplanned jealous but it
happens to men too and how it happens to
man is we think we can wait and wait and
wait because technically mostly we're
able to have children later than women
but do you know what happens age 45
you're competing with a 35 year old
version of yourself to find the same
woman who's able to have children so
there are actually more childless men
than childless woman
and I think men need to understand that
this applies to them just as much
that makes a lot of sense Stephen where
can people watch the birth cap so
birthcap.org is a website we we
um we have the part one of the
documentary is on there the other parts
are are available from members only
because we're working with some
streaming services right now to look at
possibly having them brought out later
this year
um part one is also on YouTube I caught
it on YouTube and I thought it was
absolutely fantastic so I recommend
everybody check it out there and
continue to follow it and we will go
over to locals uh join us there
he says I agree with David Attenborough
when he says all our environmental
problems become easier to solve with
fewer people and harder and ultimately
impossible to solve with even more
people
foreign
[Music]